130 logements étudiants transformer en
90 logements sociaux la résidence les
lys de la ville du pecq ce sont 57
studio 23 2 pièces et 10 3 pièces à
proximité du centre ville pour un prix
défiant toute concurrence pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée les premiers prix
des studios sont 1 200 euros les 20
mètres carrés quant au pecq on est
plutôt autour de 600 euros les 20 mètres
carrés donc voyez c'est des prix très
attractifs dans un secteur où il ya une
forte demande et il n'y a pas forcément
une offre importante déjà occupé à deux
tiers de sa capacité c'est la première
inauguration du plan prévention carences
mises en place par le département en
2018 un fonds de 17 millions d'euros
apportés pour acheter le bien puis le
revendre à des bailleurs les communes 40
c c'est à dire les communes qui n'ont
pas 25 % de logements sociaux sont
pénalisés par l'état elle paie une
amende donc le département aide de deux
façons soit en aidant à la réalisation
d'opérations de logements sociaux avec
des bailleurs on peut comme on veut le
faire à bougival à côté d'ici à viroflay
construire aussi en bail réel solidaire
c'est à dire dissocier la propriété
immobilière de la propriété foncière
cette inauguration arrive à point nommé
pour la commune elle comptabilise
maintenant 24 5 % de logements sociaux
et n'a plus à payer les 55000 euros
damende annuel nous avons été carences
et nous n'avions pas respecté notre
obligation triennal on était déjà à
l'époque à 23% donc ça va être un peu
dur pour nous ce qui est une opération
canal qui n'a pas pu se faire à l'époque
il ya certaines communes dont la mienne
ou vraiment avec la meilleure volonté du
monde on ne peut pas construire pour des
différends différentes raisons moi je
n'ai plus de réserves foncières je suis
en bord de seine j'ai les coteaux la
ville et dans la tente d'une dernière
opération ces prochains mois une
réhabilitation de 8000 m² de bureaux
pour remplir définitivement le contrat
envers l'état et dépasser les 25 % de
logements sociaux